All right.
Welcome, everybody.
Sometimes they put this session early in the morning on
Sunday. Now it's late on Tuesday,
and usually it's in a hotel, and now it's at the far
end. But let me
tell you, you're the lucky ones because you'll definitely leave here
knowing more about how NCI funds grants, how to
get funding, and the changes that are happening within the
NCI. So I should have started off introducing myself.
I'm Dan Gallahan. I'm the director of the Division of Cancer
Biology at NCI, one of the four of the
extramural granting divisions at
NCI. And we are also the largest
funder of basic cancer research, which is most of what we have here
at AACR. So welcome.
As I said, what we're trying to do today is to
inform you
both about the changes, but about the approaches in getting
funding at the NIH and the NCI specifically,
and specifically in our division, Division of Cancer Biology.
And
I did want to note that a lot has changed over the last
year, as everybody here is aware.
We've gone through some changes, but we've come out, I think
we're just as strong. And what hasn't changed, for those of you
who listened to Dr. Lattai, who's the new NCI director's
lecture, is our mission has not changed, to fund the best cancer
research that we can
with the budget that we have. He's committed to making sure that
happens, and he has encouraged us to be
able to do that, too. And so we've been
vigorously, and fortunately, there's a great staff
at the NCI in terms of the program directors.
Many of those you're going to hear about today and some others in the audience who
really understand the science and really want to make
your grant as an application as great as possible and get funded.
One of the challenges we have is obviously we get many more
applications of great science than we can support.
But we really want to look for those applications that we can help nurture along
and ensure funding.
So also, fortunately, we're joined here by
four staff members, program staff members, and these are
scientists who are also very knowledgeable of the
processes. And so we're going to go through a number of...
Let me go through that.
Oops.
Not that one.
I apologize for this.
It's a long story, but I should have loaded my own slides
and I didn't. Where's Claire?
I can't.
What I was going to say is
we have four presenters today who will cover
different aspects of the NIH, the NCI,
and specifically what goes on in our division, Division of Cancer Biology.
As I said, we support basic research in all areas of cancer
biology, and we fund
the largest number of grants
in basic research at the NCI. You can see there.
So as I said, I don't want to take up any more time, but we have four
experts. And I said, these aren't just experts, they're scientists for the
process, but also scientists in themselves. Dr.
Ghosh will talk to you about the introduction to the NCI Cancer
Grant system.
Dr. Sherrill will be talking about how to communicate with a program director.
Program directors, as you know, is your unique and
critical link to getting support at the NCI.
Dr. Karuppagoda will be talking about how
to get a successful grant application, some tips and tricks that we've learned
through the ages. She's not that old, but we've heard through the ages
anyway, in terms of attending study sections and listening to
that and getting the feedback of what we do.
And that will be a great insight also. And lastly, Dr.
McCarthy will be talking about some of the funding issues that we have.
And one of the unique things that we have now at the NCI is highlighted
topics, and she'll probably make some announcements about how we're
using those, and we go forward with that.
And what we really want to do is leave open your questions at the
end so that we can help you as much as possible for specific things,
challenges you may have, and things that we can help you with.
And a lot of the questions that you'll ask are appropriate for everyone, so
don't hesitate to ask those questions.
And I said, this is your unique collection of experts here that can really
help you and really help everybody else.
So I think what we'll do is, I will now turn it over
to Sharmi. Claire, I think I can do this. Let me see.
I'll do it. Yeah.
Believe me, I am not that helpless.
All right. Good afternoon, everyone.
Thank you for being here, and thanks to Dr.
Gallahan for the introduction. So I'm going to walk you
through the NCI Grant system, especially
if you are at the early stage of your career.
It's just demystifying the NCI
system a little bit and help you get familiar with some of
the terminologies that we use internally.So
I have no financial relationships.
So this is just to very briefly give you an overview of the
structure of NCI, one of the largest
institutes of NIH, and this is the NCI Office of the
Director. They have multiple offices and centers under them.
And then we have the Extramural Division and the Intramural Division, as Dr.
Gallahan said, that we belong to the Extramural Research Division.
And this is us, DCB, the Division of Cancer
Biology. There are three other scientific
divisions and a Division of Extramural Activities that
help put together a lot of the
administrative tasks.
So as part of the
Division of Cancer Biology, you already saw part of this factoid that Dr.
Gallahan presented. So this is our division.
The mission is to support basic cancer research in
all areas of cancer biology at academic institutions,
research foundations. And we are the
main funder for fundamental cancer
research,
and the largest organization in that sense.
And the
right side just shows the different breakdown of the
awards, whether it's for the early-stage investigators, and the
number of times people view DCB
website and all of those statistics.
This is the organization. So you already heard from Dr.
Gallahan, the director of our division, and we also have our
acting deputy director, Dr. Hanlon, in the audience.
And there are six scientific branches, and I belong to the
Cancer Cell Biology branch, and there are representatives in this
audience from other branches as well.
So,
there are Cancer Immunology, DNA and Chromosome Aberrations, Biophysics, Tumor
Biology, Tumor Metastasis, and you can see what your scientific
area is and how it's aligned with the
branches.
So, the grant mechanisms for new application, you may
hear
terms that we use, NOFOs, we used to call them FOAs earlier.
They're Notices of Funding Opportunities, and they could be
unsolicited. You're probably very familiar with the
R mechanism, the R01 grants that you apply to a
standing NOFO, and it's
investigator-initiated. But then there are also NOFOs
that are initiated by the institute, so these
are unsolicited grants. They often become programs.
They could be RFAs.
They have a set-aside money
up front, and then there could be also other types of
mechanisms, and there could be cooperative mechanisms or even
R mechanisms tied with these programs.
You need not worry about the mechanism so much.
When you are looking at a NOFO, just
review the requirements carefully and try to
design an application as strong as you can based on those
requirements.
So this is the DCB portfolio, just a schematic representation to
show that R01 is the largest
pool of applications that we administer and
oversee. And then there are other, the R35 Outstanding Investigator
Award program that is on pause at this time.
And then we also have multiple other R mechanisms and
program projects like P01s, and then also cooperative agreements,
like different types of U mechanisms.
So of course there are a lot of options which could be overwhelming
especially if you are
new to the field or trying to establish your own
independent research. So
let the research dictate the mechanism.
So you just think about the science.
That is of supreme importance, right? How large is your project?
Well, what kind of resources does it require?
Think about if you have preliminary data or if you're still at an
exploratory stage.
And then spend some time on the NIH website,
get a little familiar with what the requirements are, where things are
housed, so it doesn't come across as
such an unknown place to you when you apply.
And then my other colleagues will cover how to
look for active NOFOs and things like the Matchmaker tools, all of
these things. There are multiple tools available to make your life a little
easier, help you navigate the system.
So just browse through the system a little bit when you have time.
So
say that you have put together an R01, you had a lot of preliminary data, you
put together an R01, you have a successful lab, and then you
have expanded your research. And then you are now at a
position where you can develop these P01 projects, which are
usually three to four large projects.
They are not exactly like putting together
three different types of R01s. They have some
similarity, but it's also connected with a common theme.
That's the difference. And then you have administrative cores, you
have other types of shared resource cores that are serving those specific
projects and not
doing other things.
And we are always there, as Dr. Gallahan mentioned, the
program officers are there.
Get to know them and then reach out to them for guidance.
And then this is another just to remind you that do not
ignore the smaller grant mechanisms. Everything adds up.
Everything helps build your career and help you become
successful in the field. So there are R21 grants.
If you are at an exploratory phase, explore these grants.
NCI has once again signed on to the omnibus
NOFO that's out there since last October, I guess.
And then,
you have R03 grants, which are not a lot of money, but still some support
for up to two years, and everything helps.And
so consider those mechanisms as well.
And then cooperative agreement awards, this is almost like a
team-size
based approach that we take where NCI and NIH staff,
they're very heavily involved, not only in the concept development and
the development of the program, but also the management of
the program and looking at the health of the program once it has been put
together. So it requires
substantial commitment from the investigators.
It's often very elaborate and very different from the R01
mechanism that you may have experienced, or you're putting together an
application. And here, you can use the QR code to,
just as an example
of an RFA from the Human Tumor Atlas Network, to see how
elaborate it is, the requirements that are laid out that help you prepare an
application.
Now, all of the independent grants and the programs that we develop,
this is just a
convergence of all of that in this slide that just
showcases the different programs that we have within our
division, whether supported through cooperative agreement or our
mechanism or any other mechanism.
All of this is one place where we are headed, and you must have noticed
it in the field, that the data sharing
requirement has become more and more stringent, and there is no
way of getting around it.
Reproducibility is important. Putting your data out to the community is
important. And so NCI also has your
data. It can be housed in this cloud-based
structure that we have developed now called the Cancer Research Data Commons,
where there are six different data commons already built, and there
are multiple nodes where your data can be housed.
And then it can be there for long-term use for the scientific
community.
And if you're very early in your career, you can also explore
the training grants that we have, the F mechanism, the
K mechanism, all of this. And then you can also reach out to
a center that specifically handles the training part if you have any
questions.
So that was nine minutes.
And then
one final thing, you must have heard a lot about the funding
policies and how we are making funding decisions without
a pay line and all that. And we just want to emphasize
that scientific merit is of supreme
importance, and that's one of the most important criterion that
we use to make funding decisions. And then there are other factors, and
it's also
housed on the public
portal on NCI, and you can see how are we making
funding decisions these days.
So,
I would just like to conclude my talk by
emphasizing that as you are developing your career
in science, and you will hopefully have many
successful NIH grants, stay connected
and stay informed. Nothing is more
important than that, to just look at what is NIH
looking for these days? What are the highlighted topics?
Should I align or could I align my application with those?
And then, the guide notices to see
what information NIH is putting out.
So just stay informed. And with that,
I conclude this portion of the talk.
Great.
Thank you for your attention.
Thank you, Sharmi. Okay, we'll take questions at the end.
We're going to have a panel up here, and we'll take all your questions.
So, Solima, are you ready?
Okay. Thank you so much for being here.
I am going to talk to you about how important it is communicating with your
program director and how it's a two-way street.
These are my disclosures.
So in the next 10 minutes, I will tell you who are program
directors, what we do, when, and why to connect
with your program director, and I'll conclude the 10 minutes with telling you
what we can and we cannot do for you.
So when you submit your application to the NIH, it does not
end up in the hands of one single person.
Instead, it is handled by a coordinated team of
people. You have the scientific review officer who
manages the scientific and technical review of your application,
ensuring that your application, by putting together
an expert panel of reviewers, your application
is fairly reviewed.
They also are the ones that provide the official documentation of
your review, which is your summary statement.
Your application is also overseen by the program director
that normally oversees programmatic, scientific, and
technical aspects of your research and your application.
You also have a grants management specialist assigned to your
application. They manage all the administrative and financial
aspects of the award, including compliance and budgeting.
So together, we work together to
ensure that everything goes smoothly in the process.
So as program directors, we are your point of contact
at NCI.
We are the ones that link you to the NCI, so
you can reach out to us at any time.
We are also stewards of taxpayer funds.
We ensure that the nation's investment
in the NCI's mission is to its fullest
potential.We make sure that it's done legally
and ethically, and maximizing research progress.
We are also the ones that try and identify
gaps and opportunities in the research, and we make
recommendations to NCI leadership and NIH leadership
about any major advances in the field.
So how do you find your program officer?
The first step is to talk to your mentor, your peers,
or others that you know that have applied for an NIH
grant. They can easily give you names of program officers.
A second way is to check out the NCI divisions, offices, and
centers website for staff information.
So here is an example. Here we have the Division of Cancer Biology
website. If you go on About DCB,
you will find Contact and Staff. If you click on
that tab, you will find the list of the different
branches within our division, along with the different
program officers, their emails, and their areas of expertise.
So you can just reach out to us based on your expertise.
Another way is using the NIH RePORTER,
specifically the Matchmaker page.
This is an essential tool because,
first of all, if you copy and paste your abstract, your
specific aims, or you just do a keyword search
in the search section, this will tell you
how other funding institutes align
with your proposed research. It will also tell you
a list of program officers that are overseeing these funded
projects, and it will provide you with the list of funded projects
that align with what you are interested in.
And the program officers that you find here are actually the main ones that
are aligned with your areas of interest.
So this is a complicated slide, but bear with me.
It is
an overview of the grant application life cycle.
And as you can see in this slide,
it has many complicated steps. But
it is not really that complicated once you understand who can
help you at what step.
So as you can see here, your NCI program director or
program officer
is listed at several steps throughout
this cycle. So reach out to us at any time.
You don't have to wait to have a fully developed idea
or research proposal to reach out to us.
Reach out to us even when you're drafting your proposal.
We can provide you with scientific feedback.
We can provide you with making sure that your application or
your proposed research is in alignment with the NCI priorities.
Also, keep in mind that between the development of an
idea and submission, it takes around eight months.
So reaching out early is actually key.
So once your institution actually has submitted your
application, your application is assigned
by the Center of Scientific Review to the appropriate scientific
review officer
and a study session.
Alongside, the Center of Scientific Review also
assigns your application to a specific funding institute that
then assigns it to a specific division, who then assigns
it to a specific NCI program director.
After the review process, your application or your
grant is overseen by the grants management specialist, and they are the
ones that will reach out for any administrative follow-ups because they are the
ones that oversee any legal and administrative
problems.
Again, after the award is made, we are still your point of contact
as program officers.
So let's dig a little bit deeper into what we can do before you
submit. As I mentioned before, if you reach out to us before
you submit, we can assess if your application aligns
with the NCI priorities. We can help you find
notice of funding opportunities.
We can discuss about eligibility criteria.
We can discuss about the different types of grants that my colleague just
showed you that could be better for what you are proposing.
We can also provide you with scientific feedback, and we can
communicate any special requirements or policy updates.
After your application has been reviewed,
you can still reach out to us, even though your application has not been
discussed, because you will receive a summary statement, and we can
help you contextualize what is within that summary statement, and
we can discuss about the possible next steps.
In the pre-award phase,
we can help you resolve any issues that needs to be addressed before
your notice of award is made. We can help you resolve
issues that are pertinent to an overlap
in your science, in the use of your human subjects,
vertebrate animals.
So we can also help you in that phase.
After the award is made, we are still here for you because you will
be submitting an annual progress report every year
where you will be letting us know what's your scientific progress in the
past year and what you will be doing in the coming year.
We will be monitoring that progress, and we will be reaching out to you
if things don't add up, if we need more information, if we
need clarification. So you will still be hearing from
us.So I told you a lot about what we can
do for you, but there's also a list of things that we cannot do for you.
We can help you with your science. We can provide scientific feedback,
but we cannot tell you how to design your project.
We cannot tell you what experiments you need to be doing.
We cannot provide exemptions for submission deadlines or rule
violations. We cannot change your study section
assignment. We cannot change the NCI funding policy.
We cannot change the requirements that must be fulfilled for an award to be
issued. We cannot write your recommendation letter as your program
director, and we can only speak to you, not to your
chairperson, not to anybody else except you
about your application, your summary statement, your job position, and
status.
So the title of the talk was, "It's a Two-Way Street." So a
lot of the responsibilities that we have, I have laid out, but as
principal investigators, you
also have responsibilities. You need to keep
your eRA Commons up to date with your personal information,
your institution affiliation, your current
address, phone, email, so if we need to reach out,
we can reach out to you easily.
You also need to monitor regularly the status section of the eRA
Commons, because in this section, you will be able to see if your
application has been received, if your application has been accepted,
who is the scientific review officer assigned to your
application, which study section is going to review your application, who
is your program director. Once it's reviewed, you'll get your summary statement
in here with
all the comments. And if we need any
just-in-time requests, you will find that information also in here.
And finally, your notice of award.
Also, you need to provide all the required materials on
time, including your just-in-time, your annual progress report, as I
mentioned before, and any required certifications and
documentations, including your IRB, IACUC trainings,
and so on.
Also, it's recommended that you, as principal
investigators,
reach out to us and let us know if there are any major scientific
advances or publications. Please don't wait for the next progress report
to come in for us to know about your research.
We are excited as much as you are.
We will also reach out, too, so keep an eye out for any emails from
us. We will reach out for any grant-related questions.
We might invite you to participate in workshops, seminars, or webinars.
We
might inform you about programs relevant to your expertise and also
notify you of other opportunities.
So with this, I hope that I have convinced you that it's a two-way street,
and you communicating with us and us communicating with you
helps a smoother process to the grant life cycle. Thank you.
Great. Thanks, Cheryl. Let me point out one other thing while
Soumya's coming up, is without a pay line,
program directors, we always say, "Talk to your program directors."
Every application that gets funded goes through a program director.
Obviously, merit and score is critically important, but also,
I'll say this, every application goes through a program director, so
you should get to know them.
Good afternoon. Now that you're armed with information about
the NCI grant system and the role of a program director,
let's look at another equally important aspect of the
application process, which is submitting a successful NCI grant.
My name is Soumya Korapati, and today I'll provide you with some
pointers for putting together a successful NCI application.
I have no financial relationships to disclose.
So my talk is divided into two parts.
The first part, I will focus on core elements of a successful
grant application, and the second part, I will give you an
overview of the NIH Data Management and Sharing Policy and
how it fits into, and what its role is in the application package,
so to speak.
So there is no secret
formula for obtaining an
NIH grant. However, every successful NIH
grant has certain core elements.
Number one, addressing an important scientific topic, and in this
case, showing the robust
significance of your research and its relevance to cancer
research.
Highlighting the potential impact of your
research to the cancer field and what the results
might be
for the field itself. And then ensuring that your
project stands out by highlighting the novelty and
the innovation of your approach.
So the idea is to
have a clear and focused approach so that you can
present your work in an unambiguous manner,
provide it with clear rationale and relevance to the question that
you're asking, which would also along with
supportive preliminary data. The idea really is to
have good grantsmanship, where you pay careful
attention to details throughout the application, throughout
the grant, and
pay
meticulousMeticulously
look at following the guidelines that are required
so that you put together a strong application
coherently using simple language, and
yet emphasizing and highlighting your research project.
Really, a strong research strategy is the heart of your
application, and help reviewers
understand and appreciate the significance, innovation, and the feasibility
of your research.
And definitely align the application components with
the review criteria.
So currently, NIH and NCI follow a
simplified review framework where your
project or your application is scored on three factors.
Factor one is evaluated for the importance of research,
where the reviewers are
looking at the innovation,
significance, and the novelty of the question that you're asking,
so that at the end, your research must address a meaningful
question and would contribute something new to the field.
This factor,
it's reviewed as a numerical score.
Factor two is evaluated for rigor and feasibility, where the
reviewers are evaluating your approach
and
the scientific
quality, the quality of the science that you're presenting.
What they're looking for is the study design, methodology, and
analysis are well-reasoned and
appropriate to your project's aims.
They also consider the potential challenges and
strategies that you are addressing in your research
project.
This factor also receives a numerical score.
And finally, factor three is where the expertise and resources are
evaluated. So it's basically the reviewers are looking at the
team of scientists that you have proposed for this research, and
the availability of resources for the fulfillment of the
award.
This
factor is evaluated for sufficiency.
So all three factors
are considered to provide you the
overall impact score. However,
the
score of factor one limits how high your impact
score can be.
Which is to say, if your factor one score
is moderate or low, while factor two is really strong and
factor three is sufficient,
the possibility of your overall score being reflected
by factor one is really high. So do focus
on aiming to get a
exceptional factor one score.
And here is a QR code for some of the successful
applications that NCI and NIH
has put out on their website, and this really gives you an idea of how
successful
investigators have presented their science that got funded.
I'll wait for a moment for you guys to get the...
Okay.
I'll shift gears a bit now and talk about the
NIH Data Management and Sharing Policy.
NIH has had a long-standing
commitment to openly making the
results of NIH-funded results
available. Responsible data management and
sharing have many benefits like accelerating the
pace of biomedical research, enabling validation of research
results, and
most importantly, providing access to high-value datasets.
To promote sharing of scientific data, NIH issued
the DMS, or the Data Management and Sharing Policy in
2023. The policy seeks to promote a culture
in which data management and sharing are an integral component of a
biomedical research project, rather than an administrative or
additive one.
Data management and sharing practices should be consistent with the
FAIR principles. Which is to say that your data should be
findable, accessible, interoperable, and reusable.
Hence, all research grants that generate scientific data
must include a DMS plan, where investigators have
prospectively planned on how to preserve and share scientific
data with the scientific community.
So what does that mean for you all when you're putting together your
applications? So this is an overview, quick overview.
Plan and budget for the managing and sharing of scientific data at the
time of putting together your application.
Submit a DMS plan that make your data findable, accessible,
interoperable, and reusable.
If you notice,
in the simplified
review process, there is no mention of DMS.
DMS plans are not reviewed by the review
panel while giving you your priority score.
It is approved, the plans are approved by your NCI
program director. However, awards will not be
made until an appropriate DMS plan is received and
approved by the program director.
And once approved, you have to comply with the plan for
the period of the award. And progress of
your data sharing is reported yearly in the
Research Performance Progress Report, or the
RPPRNIH
highly encourages and recommends maximum data sharing.
However, data sharing limitations due to ethical,
legal, and technical factors
is possible, and those limitations must be described in
the DMS plan.
Protecting the privacy of human research participants is
paramount, and hence, responsible data sharing of
human research subjects is expected, keeping in mind
this expectation.
NIH recommends again, highly, to share
data in established repositories.
And there are many domain-specific NIH-supported
repositories out there. However, if you cannot
find a domain-specific repository for your data
type or
an established
repository for your data type, a generalist repository would be a
good alternative
to pursue.
And finally, and importantly, the Genomic Data Sharing
Policy, or the GDS policy, is now harmonized into the
DMS policy, meaning you do not need to
submit a GDS plan separately. It is
harmonized and combined into the DMS
policy slash plan.
So, a quick update, upcoming update.
For applications with due dates on or before May
24th, 2026, the current two-page DMS
plan format stays in effect. So currently, for the last
three years, NIH suggests a two-page DMS plan
which
addresses all the data management and sharing questions.
But effective May 25th, there has been a change
in this format, where now the recipients, that is,
investigators, are required to utilize
a new, simpler format for the plan.
So it's going to make
writing the plan simpler from your perspective.
However, the most important thing to remember is that the essence of the
NIH DMS policy remains the same. The tenets
and the philosophy of the policy remains the same, and maximum data
sharing is still encouraged. This is only a change in the
format, in the way you present your data sharing plans.
It is not a change to the policy itself.
For more information on the policy, updates, and any guidance in
writing a DMS plan, please visit our website.
My email information is on that website too, so feel free to shoot me an
email if you have anything specific, any specific questions
before or after writing the plan. And if you have any questions, feel
free to contact me.
I'll leave it at that. Thank you.
Great. Thanks a lot, Sarma. And remember, she's really
been an expert on the generation of the DMS, so don't
hesitate to reach out to her. And one other point, too, I wanted to mention.
In
your summary statement, you do have someone that listens to the
review, the program director. So that's a unique
opportunity. There's obviously a separation between program
and review, but they listen, they can give you insight into that, so that's
another great tip to why you should contact your program
director.
Awesome. Thanks, everyone. I'm going to take us through the home stretch here with
some funding opportunities and highlighted topics.
And I have nothing to disclose. So I just wanted to give a quick overview of the
types of Notices of Funding Opportunities, or NOFOs, at
NIH.
There are parent announcements, which are investigator-initiated or
unsolicited applications, often for things like R01s,
R21s, and R03s that Sharmi talked about in her
part of the session.
There are Requests for Applications, or RFAs, which are
often for grant and cooperative agreements, specifically for
programs, and those have set-aside funds.
And so some examples of those include the applications for U01s,
U54s, and U24s.
There are also Program Announcements with Special Receipt, Referral and/or
Review Considerations, or PARs, and those are often
for applications for a specific program or activity
with those special considerations that I mentioned, like a special type of
review, or special receipt dates, or special
referral guidelines.
So now we kind of know about the types of NOFOs.
Now you might be wondering, where can I find the funding opportunities?
So you can go to the Explore NIH Grant Opportunities
website. They have a nice table there, and you can actually
sort that by funding organization and select for NCI if you're
specifically interested in cancer research funding
opportunities. And you can go to the QR code there to pull
that up.
You can also go to grants.gov to find NIH funding opportunities.
And there, you can also have the option to subscribe to receive a
daily email listing of all new grant opportunities.
You can subscribe to receive notifications when changes are made to a
specific opportunity's forecast, synopsis, or packages,
and you can subscribe to receive notifications for new opportunities
matching a saved search.
And for the Division of Cancer Biology, or DCB, you can also come to our
website. We have a webpage that lists all of our funding
opportunities as
well.And we
also have a newsletter, so you can subscribe to receive the DCB
newsletter. It's a bimonthly newsletter.
What we will often include, recent DCB-supported funding
opportunities and highlighted topics, which I'll talk about
later.
We share NIH policy updates, upcoming events,
and more.
And so now, I thought I'd share some of our current DCB funding
opportunities, and I'm just going to give the high level here, but I would
encourage you, if you are interested in any of them, to go to the actual funding
opportunity announcement and read the details of it.
And I also have the QR codes here to make that easy for you.
So one is the PAR-24-306 for research
projects to enhance applicability of mammalian models for
translational research. And the final application due date is
coming up in June.
And so this actually invites applications for projects to expand,
improve, or transform the utility of mammalian
cancer and tumor models for translational research.
And that also includes things like organoids, tumoroids, and cell
models.
And so I would encourage you, if you're interested in developing
models for cancer research, to check that out.
There's a new funding opportunity
recently released in February of this year,
and that is for the Metastasis Research Network, MetNet,
or research projects, and that invites
applications that are using systems-level approaches to
address gaps and opportunities in metastasis research.
There is also a funding opportunity that
invites research grant applications for the development and
use of current and emerging molecular imaging methods to gain fundamental
insights into cancer inflammation in vivo.
And just Friday, DCB released some topics of
interest for administrative supplements.
And so the NIH policy allows for administrative supplements
within the scope of the peer-reviewed and approved project.
The topics of interest for
DCB, I'm not listing them all here for time, but they're in a
number of areas in cancer cell biology, collaboration, data
integration and reuse, metastasis and systemic effects of
cancer, modeling and methodologies, tumor heterogeneity,
and the tumor microenvironment. And I encourage you to
go to the webpage to learn more about that, and I would also
encourage you to talk to your program director if you have an
idea or are interested in a potential administrative
supplement.
And now I'm just going to talk about some highlighted topics related to
cancer biology.
And NIH highlighted topics are kind of a new thing.
They are selected research priority areas within one or
more NIH institutes, centers, or offices.
And applicants can actually submit an investigator-initiated
application in that topic area through one of the NIH
parent announcements.
And some DCB-supported highlighted topics include
one on accelerating research in celiac disease.
We're specifically interested in supporting cancer or
tumor-associated celiac disease research.
Also, one on advancing autoimmune disease research.
And NCI actually encourages research at the intersection of autoimmunity
and cancer immunology, and that includes things like immune-related
adverse events.
There's also a highlighted topic on advancing childhood and adolescent and young
adult cancer research, so really looking for
research focusing on childhood cancers.
And the fourth one is on quantum information science and
technologies for biomedical applications.
And so NCI is interested in quantum-enabled sensing,
compute, and imaging technologies that extend existing cancer
research, diagnostics, and treatment capabilities.
And so with that, I'll just open it up for the Q&A, and I'll
just leave this slide up
with some QR codes with the contact information for DCB
program directors and to the DCB website, which has a lot of that
information that we've shared throughout the session. Thanks.
Thank you.
Can everybody come up? Panelists come up. Okay.
This is the part I think is the most informative, is
listening to you asking questions of anything you have concerns about what's
been spoken here, what hasn't been spoken here.
I'll take one question online. The NCI
director mentioned the multi-year funding.
Should we be applying for multi-year funding?
I'll just answer that as people coming up here.
You can't really apply for multi-year funding per se for a typical
grant. But
some of the smaller grants that we mentioned, the
R21, the R03, the R15,
those are two-year grants, and we pay those as multi-year
funded. We pay it all up front. And here's another tip.
We have a certain number of those that we have to
grant, and so
sometimes those are priority for us to fund.
So if that's part of your research and it's something that would work for you, then
it might be wise to look at those. Again, talk to your program director.
All right. Let's start with up here.
Okay. Yeah.
Thank you for this session. It's really helpful.
So I'm Adil from Stanford. So asking
when you
write your application
and for experimental approach,
you should consider the
budget?Especially for
early career
awards like K99,
there is no
much amount for research.
It's in the budget mentioned in the application is around
30,000 per year.
And when you want to do experiments, you may
need more than that. How to consider this when you do
the application, as this will be evaluated during review?
Yeah.
Or-
Go ahead.
Yes. When you
draft and you submit your application, you have to consider the
budget for whatever proposed experiments you have.
So you will have to calculate the amount of mice, reagents,
ELISAs, whatever you're planning on doing, and come up with an appropriate budget
that is actually reviewed and
commented during the review session.
And they talk about if your budget is appropriate or not, if it's
too much, if it's too little, and if you can do what you're proposing to do
with the budget that you're asking.
So
yeah, something that you have to take into consideration when you craft your
application.
Thank you.
Just to add to that is, you can also
go for modular or non-modular budget.
So you can prepare in modules where you don't have to categorize the
items if you're requesting up to 250K
direct cost. But if you exceed that, then you have to categorize the
items, and there's no way around it.
But modules, there is some guidance there.
You can see that you can
look at the total budget that Cheryl said, and then you can
divide it by the number of modules in need, and you
can go up to 10 modules of
$25,000 each. But you're not
tied to 10 modules. Like for one year, you can request nine, for one year you
can request 10, and things like that, depending on the requirements for
that specific year.
Great. Another question?
Thank you for the wonderful talks.
I come from an R15 eligible institution, and I was wondering
if you had any specific advice for crafting R15s and also
navigating the special emphasis panel.
So rather than, I always send it to a specific study section, it always
gets shunted to a special emphasis panel.
So I was wondering if you had any advice for that process.
Sharmi, do you
want to talk about R15s?
Yeah. Sharmi Eosare: I mean, R15s are
specifically geared towards, if you're talking about the
area grants and then the REAP grants, right?
So if you're-
Or a REAP eligible institution.
You're REAP eligible. Okay. So that is more like
resource and infrastructure towards those
things. Building instead of supporting the undergrad team.
So I don't think that the R15, I mean, your experience
is it goes to special emphasis panel, and that is something that is
decided by the review office.
We don't have a say in whether it should
go to a special emphasis panel or not.
So unfortunately, we don't have a say in that.
But,
you know...
Yeah, as you might know,
one of the changes happened at NIH is that NCI used to
review a lot of different applications.
We don't review any applications again per se.
All peer review for NCI and all the other
ICs is conducted at CSR, the Center for Scientific Review.
We don't have as much input in that as we did before.
I think the R15, and I guess they're... I'm looking at Sean.
I guess they still go to a special emphasis.
Do all of them go to special, do you know?
No.
I don't know, but that's your experience.
Have all-
That's my understanding, but I'm not sure it's complete.
Yeah, that's a challenge.
R15s are something special, though.
I just mentioned the fact that it's one of those multi-year things,
grants that we're trying to encourage.
We
actually ran a small workshop. Claire, do you want to say something
about that?
Sure. Actually, yeah. Thanks. I think a few years ago we had an
R15 investigator workshop, and we do have information and
materials from that workshop that are available on the DCB
website. And you could even find some of the R15
investigators and things there, and some of the information that might be
helpful.
Wonderful, thank you.
Next.
Hi,
my name is Amy Leslie. I'm a first-year postdoc at
Stanford,
and I guess I really appreciate that you were showing
early career through mid-stage career
grants from NCI. And two questions I have
is,
do you think that the NCI F32 is ever going to come
back because other branches still have it?
And then next, the second question is that
I've been trying to watch closely after the Ace
K32 from NCI and waiting for it to drop,
but I keep messaging the program
officer, and it appears it hasn't been released yet, and it's
only for the first two years of the postdoc.
So I just want to ask
about those two and any recommendations going forward as someone who's not
clinical.
Yeah.
Sharmi, you want to...? No, all I was going to say is some of those training
grants,
if you listen to Dr. Lata yesterday, I mean, we're still going to
be supporting those training grants.
I don't know exactly the format. Our division
does not support any training grants per se, but we support
trainees on our grants.
So I'm not sure that specific case.
I would
talk to the Office of Cancer Training, and they may be able
Vignesh D. Go ahead, Vignesh D. What?
At the NCI booth.
Yeah, at the NCI booth.
Yeah. If you meet us, we can connect you or give you-
Yeah
... a name of the main point of contact for the Center for
Cancer Training that handle the F32 and in all of the training
grants, and you may benefit from reaching out to them.
Yeah.
Thank you.
Sure. I have a question online now, and it may be one
that touches a lot of different people in this sort of sense,
because one of the things has been early-stage investigators and the
funding outside the pay line. As an ESI
investigator with a 21% percentile score
studying the tumor microenvironment, how likely would funding be
considered? Well, I think, first of all,
ESIs, as Dr. Latai said, and as we've always supported,
even when we had a pay line, we would give them 5% to 6%
added. Well, we don't have a pay line now, so
what that means is we're going to be looking at every
ESI and looking at score
aside. Now, 21 is generally up in
the higher range, but we are going to be looking at score
aside every ESI specifically because we have a
certain number that we really are trying to hit, and you heard that yesterday from
Dr. Latai. So I don't know specifics of
this. Just because this individual's studying the tumor microenvironment,
that doesn't necessarily mean it's bad or good.
We have to look at that application, but we will be looking.
As I said earlier, we look at every application, especially the
ESIs.
Go ahead.
Hi. Thank you for the session.
My name is Talish Napomuceno. I'm a research scientist at Moffitt.
My question relates to my K99 application.
So I was wondering, usually, what is the timeline from getting the scores to
receiving the summary statement, and who would be the person to contact if there's
any delays?
So that would be
from the program officer cannot step in if
the summary statement has not been released.
So at that point,
before review and post-review, during that period,
reach out to the scientific review officer to see the timeline,
and they should be able to give you a
timeframe.
Yeah, normally it's around four weeks.
Yeah.
Yes.
If you haven't heard from them-
Between the scores and the summary statement release. Yeah.
I have another question here that I guess impacts everybody.
Who makes the final decisions on funding now that you don't have a pay line?
Well, even when we had a pay line, the final decisions on
funding is the NCI director. The NCI
director, right now, funding decisions have to be
done by a political appointee. He is a political
appointee. So we're fortunate in the sense that the NCI
is that our decisions to fund our grant applications can be
made by our director and don't necessarily have to go to
Building 1 is where the NIH director is.
So that part of it is something that I think is
beneficial for the National Cancer Institute, and Dr.
Latai has emphasized many times that we are
still trying to fund as many applications.
The hope is that we're funding the same number of applications that we did, not
necessarily in the last year, but that we have been funding,
and I think we're on track for that. Some of that got slowed down.
You may remember that we
had a furlough for a while. Not for a while, a long time.
I was the only one there, and believe me, that wasn't going to help anything.
But I think now we are
actively looking at the applications, recommending applications for
funding every day, every week, and working tirelessly to do that and
push those forward.
I should take this last one, I guess.
And I might need help. Many institutions abroad are eligible for some
grants as R21s and even R01s. How likely are they to get funded from
abroad? Well, I think, again,
just being abroad doesn't necessarily knock you out of funding
decisions.
So everything else will be considered in that.
The only thing that knocks you out is the indirect cost.
Please.
I was just wondering, is the NCI funding any grants on
disparities, or are they discontinued at this time?
Health disparities we are funding.
I think it often gets confused as the
DEI questions, but
the mechanism of health disparities is still something that we're
funding. We've had to go back and look at some of those applications,
but we are still funding health disparities research.
The other question I had was that for the
cancer biology,
she mentioned that you have an NIH R03 called
NOFO.
Is there a PER number for NOFO? Is there something we could take
down?
Claire?
Is it NOFO?
I don't think there is.
I think what I meant was there are parent announcements.
And NCI did recently sign on to the R21, and I believe there's also
a parent announcement for R03s and R01 awards.
Those are just unsolicited grant applications, so
it's not for a specific program or anything, but there are announcements
for those types of awards.
I just looked. Because you said it's NIH R03 NOFO, right?
That's what you described it as, right?
Yeah. And if you look at the parent
NOFOs that NIH puts out, you will see the institutes that have
signed on to itAnd then you will see that NCI is also listed if you're
interested specifically in NCI as one of the institutes.
And you also have NIH R03, R21 also, right?
Mm-hmm. Yeah.
You have both-
Yeah
... right now. So we just have to go to the NIH
site and-
Yeah. You just have to apply to the NIH NOFO that's out there.
The NOFO.
Yeah.
Okay. Thank you so much.
Thank you. Let's make this our last question.
Hi, I just wanted to thank you all for this talk.
So I'm a third-year PhD student. I was wondering if any grants that
I'm applying for and I receive,
does that go towards my PI, and do they have access to
that money, or is it all through me and the program director is through me
specifically?
I'm not sure you can apply for...
You're talking about applying for an R01 grant as a student?
No, I'm just talking about any grants in general.
The R01s for me at this stage.
A training grant, you mean?
Yeah.
So there are, I think that-
Go ahead.
Yeah. There are grants that your PI can apply for
and put you as the trainee.
And of course, that's controlled by your PI, right?
Because you're still a student at that point.
But I think
down the road, you will be able to apply your own grant that will help
you advance your career, like the K99 and all of those.
Thank you.
All right. Well, again, I want to thank the panel.
You're dedicated program directors. And thank all of you.
We're in the business of funding research, and so we're trying our
best to do what we can do, and hopefully what we've talked about today will help
you in that pursuit.